[Music]
and
no twix only tweets news
uh submitted by pikapink
hey it's a pretty cool screen name a
virginia town is threatening to jail
kids over 12
if they cause trouble during halloween
hell yeah yeah throw those [ __ ]
in jail
[ __ ] them up stupas that's true if you
think about a trick or treat
that's one day where extortion is legal
at street home to home give me some
[ __ ] candy before i tp your front
yard yup it's trick
or treat your choice they should
definitely throw these kids in where
they have the risk of getting butt
[ __ ]
yup wait no no no i don't i don't know i
don't think that's right
he's like yup i was i was with you i was
like yes
wait no no no i don't know about the
buffalo thing i don't know because those
correctional facilities
it's like correctional facility where
but [ __ ] may happen that's our slogan
oh my god
correctional facility oh but [ __ ] but
[ __ ]
may happen that's like the best
rehabilitation though
oh yeah then when you go to the front
you're like [ __ ] no no
no no no no no i like how they have a
marketing slogan like that's like their
brand slogan
because it's like it's like you're gonna
go to jail and you're gonna get
corrected by buttfuckery
oh unless i was a gay dude i wouldn't
like that
then they could start an instagram and
have before and after pictures
that'll be heaven for me it falls like
what are they all these buff strong guys
wanna [ __ ] me in a booty haul
oh yeah uh like a guy that came in like
maybe he uh
he was like sad you know before he's
like [ __ ] [ __ ] up and then after he
gets
buff [ __ ] but they [ __ ] the scent out
of them then he's like
are you guys gonna take uh taika
trick-or-treating oh not this year's too
young i think
yes we are oh we are all right
i don't know i just want to do this so
you can dress him up and you just take
it and he goes trick-or-treating
and he's nothing like this and that's
dumb but he can barely walk though
but he can literally walk up he looks
pretty solid
like miles trick-or-treating you take
him to the door and he walks up
oh no you know our neighborhood does it
right
okay okay okay no i was thinking where
do you live i was thinking we're gonna
do what they do
drive pals verdi's and like walk
[ __ ]
but you guys have a neighborhood yeah
you have a gated neighborhood
yeah yeah i forgot i forgot where we
live why you gotta go to bella's
birthdays dude
this is nice i always wanted to go there
your neighborhood's nice too dude now
that's nice paul's ready
i don't want to go back because we went
when it was too late like and then
everything every house was like way too
we have to drive we got to do that drive
house the house you gotta go
like four or five yeah super early
verdi's
i always like palace rarities so this
town i wanna go there for no reason
let's try to go there dude yeah so this
town in virginia
uh someone screenshotted chesapeake it
says trick or treat hours will be from
6pm until 8pm on october 31st it's kind
of short
for children 12 and under work on your
sprints little kids
yeah the city code says if any person
over the age of 12 years
shall engage in the activity commonly
known as trick or treat
or any other activity of similar
character or nature under
any name whatsoever he or she shall be
guilty of a misdemeanor
and shall be punished by a fine of not
less than
25 no more than 100
or by confinement in jail for not more
than six months or both wow maybe maybe
this town is a special case and the kids
go overboard
you know what i mean like like their
idea of trick but the way they awarded
it
was like if you're 13 years old and
you're trick-or-treating you're going to
jail
like that's how ridiculous that [ __ ] is
i'm behaving it when
like back in our neighborhood when
[ __ ] like 17 year olds be like
trick-or-treat like get the [ __ ] off my
property bro
trick-or-treat i was one of those why
huh what's wrong with that because it's
for [ __ ] kids i kept trick or
treating too
seventeen i thought you went through i
did it till i was 17. you wait get the
[ __ ] off my property
you're 15 16 17 you should be going to
halloween raves
yeah you should be doing drugs that kind
of candy because like
that got it you guys got it you're a kid
those [ __ ] candies
are for children yeah you should be
taking ecstasy
yeah yeah that's true because by what's
seventh grade
12 years old because by that time i was
doing some stupid ass [ __ ] like i never
did a trick
but what i love doing was dressing up
on october 30th and i would catch people
off guard with my friends
and we'll be like trick or treat and
they're like is it already halloween
they're like get some stuff and then
they'll like try to find some type of
candy to give to us and we're just
cracking
up today because they can just pull out
their cell phone and be like it's not
well yeah i mean
there's some people that would be like
it's tomorrow you guys and i were like
oh yeah
and then some people would be like
grumpy some people be happy i don't know
i thought it was funny
we should do some next level treats
where we just have a big jar of pickles
and then go trick or treat and you pull
one out of the [ __ ] juice they've
done that already that's
good cool they do stuff like that all
the time yeah or they give apples and
then the kids tp that house
you do really wack [ __ ] i did this one
year where i didn't want to like
interact with anybody
or fam so we i just put like a buck a
bucket which is no candy in it and i
just put a sign that says sorry we're
all out but i never gave out anything
damn you know what we did when we lived
in alhambra remember that alhambra house
yeah we used to play mafian
uh we don't want to interact with their
community so bad we turn out all we turn
off all the lights that's what we did in
front of the house yeah
and you know remember it's like the
living room and then the bathroom and
then our bedroom and then we just hung
out in our bedroom watch movies
yep that's really smart that's exactly
what we would do turn off all the lights
stupid
that's good that's the communication
though when the front porch light is off
that tells the neighborhood
you're gonna come here yeah some people
still they still they try to shoot their
shot that's why you do that sign says
hey
candy's all gone sorry and debunk it i
always want to try to give out candy
and i always live in a place where
people don't go trick-or-treating
or like especially because like my
apartment's like too far away from the
street or
for whatever reason so i'm always like
damn i can never give up candy
kim always looks so excited to buy candy
and give it to out and then on halloween
night she's just sitting there like
that's true why don't you come over and
give out candy at her place
yeah well i mean i have isaac to take to
go trick-or-treat
but i'm just saying like before like
when i was in high school and stuff i
wanted
to do that or like when isaac was too
little to take him out
trick-or-treating i wanted to give out
candy you know what's so interesting man
i don't even want my kid to eat candy
man
why that's just so bad for you but it's
the joys of the world
i know but now i'm just like i'm all
right i don't want my kid
well i would do is like she would make
me ration it out throughout the year
my mom didn't do none of that [ __ ] look
at my teeth
yeah they're all open the chocolate it's
all like white powder
yeah like what the [ __ ] yeah isaac never
finishes his candy like he always ends
up i always ask him like oh can i have
some he's like yeah mommy you can have
some i'm not gonna finish this at all
i'm like yeah but he's different he's a
sweet ass kid though some of these other
kids like no what are you gonna give me
for it
[ __ ] [ __ ] up that's me bro right here
okay i didn't like either because i
didn't like chocolate so like
half of it was all chocolate i just gave
it to my friend trick-or-treating at a
[ __ ] mexican
[ __ ] neighborhood like ate some good
[ __ ] and everything yeah it's like
butterscotch candy [ __ ] peanuts
oh it's bad it's [ __ ] up candy like
lucas
we had like red cinnamon ones like with
the red rocks the strawberry bonbons
what is that the one that's strawberry
that sounds fancy
no you've seen it though it's like in
that ghetto no it's a strawberry candy
it's red on the outside but it's chewy
in the middle
really i didn't know they were bomb i
only found out because of twitter i was
like those are bon bons
oh yeah yeah cheap cheap childhood asian
cameraman but it is a strawberry if you
go to like a chinese acupuncture place
there's usually a plate with [ __ ]
change and those
i don't know like why money and canyon
are in the same place and a bunch of
toothpicks sprinkle on top oh
my the the [ __ ] chiropractor i go to
right now and
right in the front desk it's just a
[ __ ] pile of like mini snickers
i'm like wow man that's it
why dude i'm just sitting there like if
i have to wait i'm eating like four of
those things dude
oh man i get embarrassed like they're
counting what i get yeah
i do miss like halloween and like being
in the spirit of it
and like doing trick-or-treating and all
that [ __ ] too though
because i grew up in a a suburb so like
it was
a ton of that [ __ ] always went down but
then ever since like i moved
out here it's not very festive because i
think it's just a hella chinese town
yeah so like they do do it but i feel
like they do it in the more suburb area
like
not in the apartments not in like that
kind of yeah
i really want to move to like more
suburbia i like it when it's like
christmas and you know how like like uh
some cities even all their street lights
would have a little candy cane on it i
like it when the whole city feels like
has that spirit it's just so magical man
it's going to be the house that's going
to pass out scripture and they're never
going to want to come
it's better than that dentist house
there's always a dentist house that
gives out [ __ ]
tooth baby toothpaste or some [ __ ] i
want that now as an adult because when
we travel it's [ __ ] awesome
give me that [ __ ] oh yeah so the
police said that they'll just be
focusing police
the police ain't pronouncing it right
dude police yeah so they're saying that
they'll just be focusing on making sure
everyone has a
safe evening and these like going to
jail
threats it's mainly for the teens that
tend to be
[ __ ] and like kick pumpkins or do
things like that
so it's not really they're not really
going to be actively looking for
violations
but still that whole notice thing is
pretty funny
so what happens when y'all don't behave
man they gotta put the law into the
matters of the government
yeah i remember there was some [ __ ]
that took my jack-o-lantern and smashed
it on my front lawn
like there are like [ __ ] out there
that just for sure do some stupid [ __ ]
yeah yeah and i remember like um in
fifth or sixth grade
the uh my friends were bragging about
jacking candy from other kids and
damn like they would just run up and
grab their bag and i'm like damn that's
[ __ ] up dude i wish you would do that
to a fat kid i'll [ __ ] eat your hand
do you remember those uh those teens in
hocus pocus
like the bully guys the ones that took
the shoes oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i sometimes run into a group
of
guys like that like just little [ __ ]
and they're just like running around
like
like scaring all the little kids i'm
just like [ __ ]
dicks my like what what pleasure do you
get out of this why
dominance there's other bigger kids
that's good but i was really fast at
dominance
it's like a dominance eagle high yeah
right it's like i couldn't
i can kind of like you know be i could
you know force my power over these kids
or whatever i don't know and it's also
entertainment
to see people like be scared yeah it's
it's so
petty but it feels good i remember like
i would see just kids like i'd be like
maybe
10 and you'll see the little
eight-year-olds like trying to go get
candy and they're trying to get to that
house but since me and my homies are
rollerblades they're like
we're gonna get there first and they're
like oh and you see all like like
[ __ ] fred flint's don't try to like
catch up but
there's no way they can catch up because
you're on rollerblades you know i felt
so bad because like in your
face when i was a kid uh because you
know i grew up in a church my dad was a
pastor everything else we used to have
something called hallelujah night
wouldn't go it sounds boring as [ __ ] no
that's actually really fun
so you have a bunch of games all sort of
stuff that's why i'm telling you right
now if you don't even believe in jesus
just
take your kid to a [ __ ] church you'll
have activities for [ __ ] days man
oh you're right there was a local church
that it was big it was almost like a car
it was a carnival they would bring like
all kinds of rides and like
booths yeah because they didn't want her
they didn't want people to celebrate
like the the demon [ __ ] and they wanted
the kids to stay
safe exactly so i remember going there
and [ __ ]
halloween [ __ ] yeah so like they would
be like okay well let's not have these
kids trick-or-treat we'll just have them
come here and they'll well they'll do
like one like quick scripture or
whatever but everything else is just fun
games for kids we would do all this
stuff
and you get a fat sack of candy and you
don't have to go trick-or-treating so
that's why i'm saying like just like but
i would be kind of an [ __ ] because i
don't want to do what all the other kids
were doing but i remember there's this
girl her name is she'll wear costumes
yeah even though but not like you want
to do demons
but like yeah super clean yeah don't be
devil [ __ ] but you could do like
superheroes whatever
oh you can't have like a demon mask yeah
probably not but like there's a lady
girl named michelle
marrying michelle shout outs to you i
was a little [ __ ] as a kid so i
remember they would try to make me do a
lot of the kids games i don't want to do
that [ __ ] because that was too [ __ ]
cool and she was like well you're gonna
get these raffles
and when you get the rabbit they call
you gonna get them i want this [ __ ] i
tore that [ __ ] through it in her face
yeah what is it wow i hate you and then
i hate oldie yeah and then you know what
happened
one of the other guys like hey bro you
know who older brother is that's big
jane's little sister i was like
so [ __ ] scared because big big james
was a [ __ ] gigantic football player i
hope he was huge dude lyman he got a
full ride scholarship to play football
did you hear that big james kick david's
ass
james so i got really [ __ ] scared and
everybody goes back to sacramento every
once in a while
i just sat there i was like this guy's
gonna [ __ ] kill me i got [ __ ]
scared
and i was that little you're all taping
the raffle ticket back together
later on when i go back to sacramento
i'll show you guys the the little
pin that they took a picture of you and
they made it for you for vbs like
hallelujah night
and it's just me on a wall like this
i have evidence of it i remember they
did this game where like um
we had a little bible verse and we had
to memorize it
but we went through this like maze oh at
the end of the maze you have to say the
bible verse and then you get candy
that [ __ ] was fun
my